the battlefield 1 beta has been wrapped
for a few weeks giving dice time to
incorporate your feedback I'm Tony and
this is your new and improved GameSpot
news update lead world designer Daniel
Berlin has made a blog post talking
about the three areas getting worked on
first scoring and conquest mode is being
changed now both capturing objectives
and getting kills will add to your
team's overall score rush mode is also
being worked on though Berlin didn't
offer any specifics and finally
multiplayer balancing is being fixed
with a focus on vehicles and horses the
overall strength of light tanks and
horses are being tweaked and there may
be a new anti-vehicle gadget coming to
the support class battlefield one had
the biggest beta in EA history so dice
has had plenty of feedback to comb
through the full game is coming to ps4
xbox one and pc on october 21st stay
tuned to gamespot for plenty more
coverage and gameplay and for all the
biggest battlefield news you're already
in the right place